technology has become more intertwined
with our daily lives hence it is no
surprise that the need for skilled cyber
security professionals is on the rise
cyber security is a lucrative field and
there is a dearth of skilled cyber
security experts therefore currently a
career in cyber security is something
you should consider if you're looking
for an interesting job role on that note
hey everyone welcome to yet another
exciting video by simplylearn which will
take you through the top 10 highest
paying cybersecurity jobs for 2022 but
before we begin if you are new here and
haven't subscribed already make sure to
hit the subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting tech videos every
day so let's get started
at number 10 we have the job role of a
cyber security analyst
cyber security and lists are
professionals who keep a constant check
on any threat and monitor the company's
network for potential vulnerabilities
they react swiftly to restore protection
if compromised they identify and correct
flaws uncovered in the company's
applications programs security systems
computer networks and more
cyber security analysts even recommend
ways to improve the businesses overall
security and communicate the specific
measures to be taken they compile
ongoing safety reports document security
issues and measures taken to resolve
them
now let's have a look at the salary of a
cyber security analyst
according to glassdoor a cybersecurity
analyst in the united states earns about
80 000 us dollars per annum and in india
you can earn nearly 6 lakh rupees
annually
next on our list we have the job role of
a network engineer
a network engineer is a person who
understands the structure and network
essentials of the entire organization at
a macro level
they design and maintain any network
that supports the company's life cycle
and growth opportunities
network engineers take charge of the
configuration and installation of
network devices and services
they also collaborate with the security
team and ensure network security through
the implementation of tools and
procedures in line with them
they monitor network performance and
ensure reliability and availability
according to glassdoor a network
engineer in the us earns over 85 000 us
dollars per annum and in india the
average salary is 4 lakhs annually
moving on the next job role on our list
is that of an ethical hacker ethical
hackers are network security consultants
who identify and exploit system
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do
they are also known as white hat hackers
they scan the network and systems for
vulnerabilities before a black hat
hacker would ethical hackers probe and
test their network using various
penetration tools and software
additionally they also design new
penetration tools and document the test
results
according to pay scale in the us a
certified ethical hacker earns around 96
000 on an annual average basis and in
india they make around 5 lakh rupees per
annum
moving to our next job role we have
malware analyst a malware analyst
analyzes malicious software that
includes bots worms and trojans to
understand the nature of their threat a
malware analyst has a dual mentality by
being both forward thinking and reverse
thinking
moving on to the responsibilities of a
malware analyst
firstly they use tools and expert level
knowledge to help decide what kind of
malware they are dissembling and if they
have encountered this particular kind of
malware before you will use dynamic
malware analysis tools to achieve
insight into software attacks secondly
they also uncover hidden indicators of
compromise that should be blocked and
keep an organization's software updated
to protect against the latest malware
threats
according to glasto in the us a malware
analyst can earn about 97 000
and the average salary for a malware
analyst is around five lakh rupees in
india
up next we have another very interesting
job role that is information security
analyst
an information security analyst is an
expert who plans implements upgrades and
scrutinizes security protocols to
safeguard an organization's computer
networks and information
these professionals play a vital role in
the public private and non-profit
business sectors because they shield a
company's sensitive and fundamental
information
they use data encryption firewalls and
other relevant security tools and
applications to cover and protect
transfers of secret digital information
information security analysts perform
risk assessments audits and tests to
ensure the proper functioning of data
processing activities and security
measures
as per glasgow the national average
salary of an information security and
list is around 99 000
per annum in the states and as per
indeed.com in india you can earn nearly
7 lakh rupees per annum
let's have a look at the next highest
paying cyber security jobs
that is cyber security engineer
a cyber security engineer helps to
design and implement methodologies to
secure the organization's cyberspace
they also help in testing and monitoring
systems frequently to make sure that all
of the systems are up to date and work
perfectly to defend the information
they troubleshoot security and network
problems and ensure that the
organization's data and infrastructure
are protected by enabling the
appropriate security controls
cyber security engineers also conduct
tests and scans to identify any
vulnerabilities in the network and
system
talking about the salary in the united
states a cyber security engineer earns
over 101 000 dollars per annum
as per pay scale the average salary for
a cyber security engineer in india is
nearly 7 lakh rupees
moving on to the next job role we have
senior security consultant
a senior security consultant protects
their clients network through regular
situational assessments
senior security consultants are required
to carry out an assessment of security
networks to spot a system's
vulnerabilities strengths and weaknesses
following which they guide different it
teams in strengthening their security by
helping them pick the right solutions
like new techniques or tools
they also create preventive measures
against future cyber attacks
according to indeed the average annual
salary of a senior security consultant
in the states is around 104 thousand
dollars and in india it is nearly 12
lakh rupees
next we have the role of an application
security engineer
application security engineers work with
product managers and developers to plan
and implement security releases
in order to understand any
vulnerabilities within products they
carry out threat modeling tests dynamic
tests and security reviews
following this they optimize a given
product's efficacy
they ensure that every step of the
software development lifecycle follows
best security practices
they also help in testing the
application against security risks
before release
according to glassdoor in the us an
application security engineer earns
around 110 000
on an annual average basis and in india
they make around 9 lakh rupees per annum
moving on to our next job role we have
security architect a security architect
researches and plans the security
elements for their firms
they formulate company procedures and
user guides they design robust security
structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks
additionally they also approve the
installation of vpn routers and
firewalls
according to glassdoor a security
architect in the u.s makes a handsome
sum of 150 000 dollars a year on an
average and in india they make around 20
lakh rupees per annum
and finally at number one on our list we
have the role of a chief information
security officer ciso
cisos are senior level officers in an
organization their duty is to ensure the
safety of the information
they develop implement and maintain
information security and risk management
programs
additionally they also interact with
stakeholders and regularly brief them
with information security concerns
according to glassdoor the average
annual salary of a chief information
security officer in the states is a
whopping 195 000
and in india it is 19 lakh rupees per
annum
so those were the top 10 highest paying
cyber security jobs for 2022
now let's have a look at the companies
hiring cyber security professionals
here we have deloitte
netapp kpmg
bosch hp
samsung cgi and ge to name a few
so with that we have come to the end of
this video on the top 10 highest paying
cyber security jobs for 2022.
think we missed anything important do
let us know in the comment section below
thank you so much for being here and do
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
[Music]
there if you like this video subscribe
to the simply learn youtube channel and
click here to watch similar videos turn
it up and get certified click here